[Music]
the key point there is
you've got to enjoy what you do every
day and for me
that's working with very smart people
it's working on new problems
you know every time we think hey we've
had a little bit of success we're pretty
careful not to dwell on it too much
because
the bar gets raised
well i love my work the work of the
foundation is super interesting i get to
meet with the scientists i get to go out
in the field i do think your habits are
sort of set in your 20s and 30s
and by my standards of the 20s you know
i didn't believe in weekends back then
uh not to mention vacations so i'm you
know fairly
lazy compared to myself in my 20s where
i was a true
uh fanatic you know all i believed in
was working on software
night and day and and for my 20s that
was perfect i didn't have a wife or
family
uh at all and my role was very
hands-on role you know i i'm very lucky
that my foundation work
the part-time work i do for microsoft i
see that extending you know for decades
into the future and having an
understanding of innovation
uh you know i think shaping innovation
in many of these areas uh there is a
unique role that i can
i can help play
i think the ability that has helped me
in lots of things
is a kind of measurement
scientific framework where i go in and
say
did anybody handle this well what are
the very best practices
do we have numbers on that and let's get
everybody measuring what they're doing
and so they can strive to match
what that the best achievement is for us
often that's
something like getting the vaccines out
to all the children
some very poor countries uh do that
extremely well because they get down to
that local level and measure the
activity they make sure the inventory is
there they make sure the workers are
showing up
so for me i always looked at how can we
do measure
better measurement and use that to drive
the very best practices
in line with the promise of this age i
want to exhort
each of the graduates here to take on an
issue
a complex problem a deep inequity and
become a specialist on it
if you make it the focus of your career
that would be phenomenal
but you don't have to do that to make an
impact
for a few hours every week you can use
the growing power
of the internet to get informed
find others with the same interests see
the barriers
and find ways to cut through them don't
let
complexity stop you be active activists
take on big inequities i feel sure
it will be one of the great experiences
of your lives
i'm a weird dropout because i take
college courses all the time
i love learning company courses and
and things so i loved being a student
and
there were smart people around and you
know they fed you
and they gave you these nice grades that
made you feel smart
uh so i i feel it was unfortunate
uh that i didn't get to stay there but i
don't think i missed
any knowledge because you know whatever
i needed to learn i would
i was still in a a learning mode
well this idea of reading in general
if you can do that then you can create
an agent that helps a student like
a one-on-one tutor would you know
there's nothing that matches a great
one-on-one tutor teaching somebody
that's always the gold standard that all
other teaching methodologies
uh are compared to you know if you want
to learn computer science
just you know knuth wrote the book buy
it okay
uh you know read it and do the problems
for if you really
think you know this thing if you want to
learn physics feynman wrote the book
just read the damn book it's all there
well i wish more people could actually
get to these countries you know
uh join the peace corps spend time even
uh just
spending a few weeks there and see how
great the needs are and see the progress
a lot of uh you know volunteer work
in the united states builds that sense
of okay we care about other humans even
you know beyond our own uh family group
even people have very different
experiences so
you know at a young age a little bit of
giving money away
you know to form that habit and picking
which things you really want to give to
including lots of things here in the us
and
getting involved with volunteer time
those are the people
uh who i think will help kind of bring
the world together and
you know avoid uh just this divisiveness
uh that is is my greatest concern
you